PLAY AGAINST TEAMS O
BROTHER.
>> Jim: SAY IT LIKE THAT ON THEN
IT.
SHOT GOES WIDE FROM RISTOLAINEN
TRAVIS SANHEIM IS THERE,
CHANGES THE HUGHES LOSES HIS VES
DOWN.
FLYERS MOVING BACK, WILLMAN GIV
RISTOLAINEN.
ATKINSON SCORE
RIGHT THERE, IN D,
TRYING TO GET TO IR. HAS SCOREDE
SAVE!
HE RUBS BRATT .
BUMPED INTO
BRETT WHO WILL PLAY TO THE
POINT.
KEEPS IT IN THE ZONE.
THEY'VE BEEN IN THE ZONE
THE LOOSE PUCK. S MOVING OUT.  ,
EXIT THE ZONE,CKLY FLYERS.
INTO THE AIR TO THE CIRCLE,
SHOT AND SCORE.
JUST.
THE SHIFT, DOES NOT MAKE
CONTACT.
HERE ITHE
MOST PART BUT JERSEY.
AWFUL BLACKWOO
ROLE.
CARTER HARBY HART.
SAFETY NETTING SOMEWHERE ALO6-6D
PERIOD.   NOT GETTING
COMPLETELY.
DOES NOT MATTER, FLYERS HAVE I
PROVOROV.
WATCH THE PLAY BY  ATKINSON.N.
IN THE MIDDLE STOLEN.
LINDBLOM FLYERS AND
ATKINSNSERE IS USED.
THE FIRST SHIFT.PIECE OF IT.
MOMENT AGAIN FOR THE SHOT AND
FARGO CENTER. FOR YOUR POSITIO
GOOD COMPETITION YOU HAVE TOE.
A LITTLE HOTSOMETHING
>> Keith: DON'T LOSE THEM THE